on va se plonger évidemment dans les
détails de cette campagne avec vous
lilian melet dans un instant mais avant
coup de projecteur sur le dépôt des
candidatures c'est la dernière ligne
droite pour les postulants jeudi à 18
heures ce sera terminé stéphanie des
pierres et isabelle rivière se sont
rendus à ficin une petite commune willis
vient tout juste d'être déposée après
beaucoup de difficultés puissent 1 780
habitants sur la route des grands crus
madame le maire vous que les derniers
dossiers avant de passer la main
geneviève pelletier ne se représente pas
après huit ans aux commandes du village
elle estime qu'elle a fait son temps
même chose pour ses quatre adjoints et
jusqu'à ce week end elle a bien cru
qu'il n'y aurait pas de candidat à la
succession
aujourd'hui à les rassurer en partie je
m'interroge un petit peu sur les le
manque que deux d'entousiasme ou le
manque de motivation pour la fonction
municipale et c'est un peu inquiétant
pour une commune qui à près de 800
habitants d'avoir autant de mal à
trouver des candidats
désormais la liste est presque complète
14 candidats pour 15 sièges à pourvoir
au conseil municipal c'est quand même
suffisant parmi les candidats gilbert
rigaud depuis le mois de novembre avec
trois autres membres de l'équipe
municipale sortante ce retraité a
cherché des volontaires courrier
individuel réunion et même porte-à-porte
convaincre ses concitoyens de s'engager
a été très difficile je pense que on
favorise plus les les loisirs au
bénévolat parce que c'est du temps à
consacrer des gens notre village sur la
population
on les gens retraités il ya beaucoup de
retraités qui n'ont pas le temps ca c on
entend souvent
dossier sous le bras gilbert rigaud
peut-on s'en aller à la préfecture pour
déposer officiellement les quatorze
candidatures mais mardi matin en côte
d'or une soixantaine de villages de
moins de 1000 habitants n'avait encore
aucun candidat déclaré jeudi à 18 heures
ce sera trop tard pour le premier tour
mais pas pour le second
il ya une petite subtilité c'est à dire
que même si pour le premier tour il n'y
avait pas de candidature il pourrait y
en avoir entre le premier et le second
tour et à ce moment là il pourrait
malgré tout y avoir une élection au
second tour faute de candidats en
revanche au premier et au second tour
pas d'élection c'est la préfecture qui
se chargera de gérer la commune est
effectivement une solution transition
est alors mise en place voyons tout de
suite avec vous arnaud le scénario prévu
par la loi alors qu'en mai cas de figure
pas de candidats n'ont pas d'élection
délégation spéciale de trois personnes
est missionné pour assurer les affaires
courantes pendant trois mois jusqu'à un
nouveau scrutin signature pas de
volontaires nouveau délai cas extrêmes
la commune peut être rattaché à une
voisine une situation inédite il ya déjà
des cas de fusion volontaire mais pas de
rapprochement sous la contrainte en
général cette menace suggère des
vocations un seul candidat attention ça
ne va pas non plus un conseil municipal
c'est au moins un maire et un adjoint il
faut donc de nom et puis si le nombre de
candidats est inférieur au nombre de
sièges aux conseils dans les communes de
moins de 1000 habitants pas de problème
de nouveaux candidats peuvent se
déclarer donc entre les deux tours en
revanche au dessus de 1000 habitants il
faut des listes complètes on rappelle
l'échéance jeudi 18h pour le premier
tour merci arnaud j'ajoute qu'à l'heure
du pointage il reste 109 communes de
côte-d'or de moins de 1000 habitants qui
n'ont pas de candidat et c'est dans
l'yonne je vais y arriver 23 communes en
côte-d'or et 14 en saône-et-loire et
puis maintenant lilian comme chaque soir
groupe lensois une commune oui nous
continuons notre tour de vous run des
communes en jeu avec une visite à
chevigny saint sauveur dans la banlieue
dijonnaise commune a longtemps été
dirigé à droite par l'inamovible lucien
brenot il y avait habituellement peu de
suspense aux municipales mais le décès
de lucien brenot a ouvert une véritable
guerre de succession à droite michel
rogers devenu maire brigue un nouveau
mandat mais l'ancien premier adjoint
jean perrin revendique lui aussi
l'héritage un conflit qui pourrait faire
la sphère de louis-le-grand le candidat
de la gauche explications de christophe
taris et de damien arabe et zen
c'est une guerre de succession qui ne
dit pas vraiment son nom mais à chevigny
saint sauveur c'est bien l'héritage de
lucien brenot qui est en jeu maire
pendant près de 30 ans de la commune il
est décédé en octobre 2012 et c'est son
premier adjoint michel rodde g qui lui a
succédé à son bureau investi par l'ump
soutenu par l'ue dit ils revendiquent un
héritage naturel c'était le souhait de
lucien brenot quelques semaines avant
malheureusement son décès il m'a dit
michel tu reprendras la liste comme il
avait d'ailleurs en 1904 en 1987 dans
une réunion au polygone dimanche après
midi et donc j'ai suivi naturellement le
soin les servants d'autel était la non
le serai naturellement de tous mes
collègues du conseil municipal tous
monette sa majorité mais un autre
candidat revendique aussi l'héritage en
ferrain longtemps premier adjoint mais
absent de la dernière mandature le
président de l'ump y refuse toute
étiquette politique même s'il penche à
droite avec la présence dans sa liste de
pascal caravelle est également de la
femme de lucien brenot il ya eu un maire
qui a bâti chevigny qui est lucien
brenot il a dit que pour le remplacer
après son décès c'est est le suivant de
liste et il a dit le seul qui est
capable de gérer la commune c'est jean
perrin on a été ensemble pendant 25 ans
j'étais son premier adjoint j'ai été son
collaborateur parlementaire quand il
était député il me connaissait bien il
me connaît bien et je veux dire tout le
monde a adhéré à cette idée et donc il
n'y a pas de succession il ya et bien
plus il ya surtout un projet à faire et
à bâtir
dans ce contexte de division le candidat
de la gauche louis legrand qui avait
obtenu 42 % des voix en 2008 nourrit
beaucoup d'espoirs dans une ville qui
est resté à quai du tramway et qui avait
placé françois hollande en tête à la
présidentielle
il propose une liste de large
rassemblement et compte surfer sur ses
liens privilégiés avec l'agglomération
dijonnaise ce qui va beaucoup compter
puisque c'est une élection locale c'est
la situation locale on est dans une
agglomération qui est très bien gérée on
est à côté d'une très grande ville
dijon qui a un rayonnement que dijon n'a
jamais connu depuis que rebsamen et mer
dijon est connu et un rayonnement très
très important je pense qu'on a plus
bénéficié de cet élan plutôt que de dieu
du contexte national alors la droite
peut-elle perdre ce bastion reste une
grande inconnue dans ce scrutin les
nouveaux électeurs car chevigny a
beaucoup poussé en trente ans elle a
multiplié par 4 sa population
deux informations dans la campagne il
n'y aura pas de liste front national à
cosne cours sur loire dans la nièvre est
à sens dans l'yonne il n'y aura pas de
liste front de gauche la candidate a
jeté l'épongé ce soir il y aura donc six
listes à sens et on passe au mot du jour
et aujourd'hui ces listes oui on l'a
déjà dit dans ce journal c'est en ce
moment l'obsession des préfectures qui
les attendent et qui les examine et
l'obsession des candidats qui essaie de
les compléter et de les déposer et donc
c'est un de nos 15 mots de cette
campagne
liste non féminin désignant une suite
d'éléments inscrire les uns en dessous
des autres en matière électorale c'est
un peu comme pour vos courses sans liste
vous ne pouvez faire si ce n'est erré
comme une âme en peine au rayon fromage
au bureau de vote numéro 7 sans pouvoir
remplir votre panier ou bien les urnes
dans un scrutin bien mais c'est un peu
le caddie qui relie la ménagère à la
caissière mais sans les petites
roulettes et le siège enfant sur le
devant lui auront une pile poil au
milieu de l'électeur et du candidat
inscrit chacun de son côté de la boîte
sur une liste pour figurer sur la liste
des électeurs comme sur la liste des
candidats il faut avoir 18 ans si vous
êtes électeur rien ne vous oblige à être
candidat en revanche pour être candidat
il est fortement recommandé d'être
électeur un peu comme les caisses panier
ou vous gagnez vous même vos courses
pour les municipales 2014 date limite de
péremption but de dépôt des candidatures
le 6 mars et cette fois-ci chaque liste
de candidats doit être paritaires un
candidat doit suivre ont précédé une
candidate ou inversement sauf pour les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants où
là il est encore permis que monsieur
assiste au conseil municipal pendant que
madame elle ira faire les courses
elle et lilian vous avez jeté un coup
d'oeil sur les réseaux sociaux il s'y
passe beaucoup de choses du plus sérieux
au plus souriant très sérieux l'équipe
de campagne du maire ump de tel en côte
d'or qui rappelle qu'il est un grand
pourfendeur de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires qu'il qualifie de raquette et
qu'ils refusent d'appliquer une tranche
de vie en 140 signes la longueur d'un
tweet le secrétaire départemental du
front national de saône et loire
sébastien loin qui raconte son passage
semble-t-il mouvementée sur le marché de
louhans où il est candidat lui et et
dégagent écrit-il et il conclut avec
humour tournée rapide 140 signes c'est
court mais chez guy ferrer à auxerre on
fait encore plus court avec une
transcription de ces discours très
découpé un premier message qui dit je
vous le dis et je vous le redis et la
suspense il faut attendre un peu pour
avoir la suite en l'occurrence il n'y
aura pas de centre d'enfouissement ouf
et puis il ya la grande mode du moment
ses filles oui le selphy c'est une photo
individuelle ou de groupe qu'on prend
comme ça avec son propre téléphone le
cmfi pris pendant la soirée des oscars
avec des stars a été retweeté plusieurs
millions deux fois et a déclenché une
vague d'imitation y compris dans la
politique et le sel fille du jour vous
le voyez et celui de l'équipe de
françois rebsamen à dijon j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour lancer un concours aux
candidats et aux équipes politiques de
la région on attend vos selphy on les
passera dans le journal des municipales
un peu d'humour ça ne fait pas forcément
mal dans la campagne web et puis on
attend de votre ligne en merci à demain